en esta oficina en parís sólo un puñado
de los empleados trabaja presencialmente
el resto lo hace desde casa los que
quieran venir deben hacer una reserva
los empleados se inscriben para un turno
esto nos permite planificar para un
máximo de seis personas en la oficina
tras cerrarse el registro y solos que si
bien esta empresa hace todo lo posible
no todos siguen el juego a medida que el
gobierno endurece las restricciones por
coronavirus espera que los trabajadores
estén un solo día en la oficina
pero soy asistente de implantes dentales
por lo que no es posible trabajar de
forma remota y trabajar desde casa se
siente como si estuviera siempre en la
oficina trabajas más tarde de lo
habitual no hay descansos
incluso antes de los últimos cierres se
ha fomentado el teletrabajo sin embargo
una encuesta realizada a principios de
marzo mostró que sólo el 13 por ciento
de los empleados trabaja desde casa y el
65% va a su oficina el gobierno está
presionando a las autoridades locales
para que tomen medidas enérgicas pero
sus posibilidades son limitadas y se han
aprobado muchas leyes desde marzo de
2020 ninguna de ellas requiere que las
empresas trabajen de forma remota
utilizadas en el último año se han hecho
unas 65 mil inspecciones para probar el
cumplimiento del trabajo remoto hasta el
momento solo se han emitido 55
advertencias formales el gobierno dice
que ahora se realizarán más inspecciones
particularmente en los sectores
bancarios y de seguros